nos preguntan cuántas relaciones
proporcionales se muestran en el
siguiente plano coordenada y tenemos las
opciones vamos a ver el plano coordinado
para pensar cuántas relaciones están
representadas pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolverlo
hagámoslo juntos si estamos pensando en
una relación proporcional o en la
gráfica de una relación proporcional
debería haber dos cosas que estamos
buscando la primera que debería ser una
recta debería ser una relación lineal
entre dos variables y debería hacer
alguna constante de proporcionalidad
multiplicada por x entonces
inmediatamente descartamos nuestra curva
verde aquí porque no es una recta no
tiene una relación constante entre ya
que es una constante de proporcionalidad
multiplicada por equis y por la misma
razón descartamos la curva azul que pasa
con esta recta morada
esto podría ser tentador porque es una
recta pero no pasa por el origen cuando
x es 230 x x mientras que cuando x es 4
que es 1 x x
y cuando x 6 que parece ser uno y un
tercio x x de modo que no tenemos la
misma constante de proporcionalidad todo
el tiempo entonces tenemos cero
relaciones proporcionales representadas
aquí hagamos otro ejemplo natalie es
experta en tiro con arco la siguiente
tabla muestra su puntuación con base en
el número de veces que dio en el blanco
veces que dio en el blanco puntos traza
en una gráfica los pares ordenados de la
tabla muy bien el primero es 13 aquí lo
estoy haciendo en khan academy mi eje
horizontal son los tiros en el blanco y
el eje vertical son los puntos entonces
un tirón del blanco tres puntos este va
a ser un tiro en el blanco y éste va a
ser tres puntos luego tengo dos tiros en
el blanco seis puntos
entonces dos tiros
seis puntos y luego voy a tener cinco
tiros en el blanco 15 puntos entonces 5
tiros en el blanco y este va a ser 15
puntos y esto parece que es una relación
proporcional en cada situación mi
puntuación es igual a 3 multiplicado por
los tiros en el blanco así que mi
constante de proporcionalidad es igual a
y si tratas de conectar estos puntos con
una línea recta puedes ver que será una
recta una recta que pasa por estos tres
puntos y por el origen
los puntos de natalie son proporcionales
al número de veces que dio en el blanco
sí absolutamente
hasta el próximo vídeo